Sean Spicer great to be back yeah
pleasure I think everybody knows you but
who are you and what do you do for those
that don't uh I host a show on Newsmax
five o'clock every night I just put out
a brand new book called the parrots Go
Bananas it's available on bravebooks.com
talks about the ills of fake news and
you want to talk about a great deal I
mean you mentioned Public Square these
are guys who put out great Christian
patriotic books uh that that speak to
our values and they get to what uh they
allow kids to actually read something as
a father of two kids that are 12 years
old you want something that you can have
your kids that have something that
builds character that talks about
something that you can feel comfortable
as a parent knowing that they're not
being indoctrinated with and you know I
don't actually talk about fake news in
the book but it's something that you can
read to your kids and know that they're
dealing with issues that that they're
going to face as children that they know
how to do the right thing so uh you know
Brave books has been a great partner to
help educate kids